We're so lucky to have dogs.
We really are
so lucky to have dogs.
You know, it sounds silly,
but they're great teachers.
They really do show us
the best that we can be.
When they do what they do,
the way we feel in response
is such a great reminder
that that's part of our nature as well.
[dog barks]
We really serve each other so well.
There's such an eagerness in them too,
to make us happy
and make us whole.
And knowing that's it's without
an egoic drive,
that it is kind of an intrinsic part
of their nature,
makes it that much more pure.
Put this relationship anywhere,
anytime, any place,
it's going to kind of have the same result
and that's special.
[dog barks]
He gets it.
[dog moans]
[laughs]